in this lesson we're going to talk about
rational exponents so this is definitely
something you want to understand for the
you revised s80 what a rational
exponents basically rational means ratio
so they're fractional exponents so if
you want to formula this is a good one
to memorize you've got X to the M over N
and the denominator represents the root
ok this index right here and the
numerator the M represents the power so
you can either take the power first and
a root second or you could take the
route first and then raise it to the
power second so i'll show you some
examples just to refresh your memory if
I you forgot or if you never learned
this before so Steve is 3 here this is
really like the cube root of 8 and then
the numerator the two that's really the
power so what number times itself three
times in at eight well that would be to
write so this is going to equal 2
squared when you square something that
means you have that number times itself
right so two times so two times two is
four now the other way to do this as you
can see a lot 8 squared is 64 and then
take the cube root of sixty-four but
you're still going to get four so I like
to do the denominator which is the root
first and then the numerator which is
the power second okay so this one is 16
to the three force power really looking
at the fourth root of 16 because the
denominator before that's the root of
the index and then we're going to raise
it to the third power so what number
times itself four times in 16 now would
be 2 because 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
and four times and then we're cubing
that so 2 cubed is actually eight that's
two times two times two or three times
so those are some examples let's get
into some additional examples here see
if you can do these on your own go ahead
and pause the video it says which is
equivalent to 25 to the three force
powers at ABC or D so go ahead and pause
the video see if you can do this one one
thing that I notice here is that 25 is 5
squared right okay and then when you
have a power to a power you remember
from the properties of exponents you can
multiply so this is actually going to be
5 to the three halves and then here what
we can do is the denominator is the root
right and the numerator is the power
okay
so you could think of this as like the
square root of 5 g square root of 5
cubed well if u cube the square root of
5 that's really like 5 times 5 times 5
squared of 53 times right square root of
five times square 25 is squared of 25
which is five and we've got this 5 left
over so it looks like it's going to be 5
squared of five letter C is the best
answer there so here they had us do
quite a few steps you had to write have
a straight 25 is 5 squared then we had a
power to a power we multiply and then we
had to realize that the denominator is
the root and the numerators the power
and then simplify further so that was a
good problem okay example 2 it says it's
em to the c divided by three power
equals 9 for positive integers and see
what is one possible value for C okay so
see if you can pause the video and do
this one on your own and we'll go
through it together so basically they're
kind of leaving us you know kind of just
out there right we're trying to solve
this we've got two variables and then
see and they're just saying you know
what's a one possible value for C right
well okay so the denominator remember
that's the route so this is really
saying the cube root of m okay all
raised to the numerator which is a/c
power equals 9 so here you can go play
Rallis a little bit but basically what
you could do is you could say well hmm I
could take the cube root of like say for
example 27 ok so the cube root of
twenty-seven to the sea power okay cube
root of twenty-seven that's I know that
one that's pretty easy that's three so
now we have like three to the sea power
is nine well three squared is 9 so C
could be too so that's just one possible
answer but the key thing in this problem
was really knowing that the denominator
is the root the numerators the power and
then you can go ahead and you know solve
it from there so again go ahead and
review this formula here for rational
exponents and if you need to review this
lesson go ahead and do that I'll see you
in the next lesson